le projet actuel c'est un projet qui ne
verra pas le jour il n'y aura pas deux
usines de liquéfaction sur la côté de
saguenay c'est la fin d'un rêve pour
certains
celle d'un cauchemar pour d'autres le
conseil des ministres s'est appuyé sur
les conclusions très critique du rapport
du bape pour rendre sa décision
le ministre de l'environnement et de la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
soutient que gnl québec n'a pas su
démontrer l'acceptabilité sociale de son
projet sa contribution à la transition
énergétique et à la diminution des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre trois
conditions essentielles pour que le
projet puisse aller de l'avant
c'est un projet qui au plus de
désavantages que davantage donc projet
qui est plus risquée c'est évident que
l'on dit il faut être responsable pour
nos citoyens pour nos générations
futures
puis c'est un projet qui était quand
même sur 25 ans l'idée de construire une
usine de liquéfaction de gaz naturel à
saguenay polarise l'opinion publique
depuis ses débuts de nombreux groupes
environnementaux des scientifiques et
des élus poussent un soupir de
soulagement avec le projet gnl
on aurait augmenté les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre donc il y aura ensuite
localement c'est une un soulagement pour
la biodiversité donc pour les bélougas
qui seront pas perturbés par les
méthaniers et dans un communiqué gnl
québec se dit déçue et surprise par la
décision
au saguenay-lac-saint-jean le monde des
affaires comptait sur ce projet pour
diversifier l'économie
pareil pour les mouvement citoyen créé
pour soutenir gnl québec
même la ville s'était montré en faveur
de la construction de l'usiné
c'est évident qu'on est déçu c'est quand
même un projet qui au niveau des
perspectives d'emploi permettait
d'envisager la création de paysans pop
et retombées économiques pour la ville
et pour le québec
la décision du gouvernement signe aussi
le glas de la construction d'un gazoduc
de 780 km qui devait permettre
d'acheminer le gaz naturel jusqu'à
saguenay ce projet est celui de gnl
québec ne peuvent tout simplement pas
existé l'un sans l'autre
ils se mirent à chailly radio canada
saguenay